hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hit who gachi I don't
know if I'm pronouncing that right but I
didn't pronounce Tamagotchi either which
is a good Segway and know what I was
gonna talk about high-five me great job
me I'm the king of talking to myself
alone Oh God
anyway so if you guys remember
Tamagotchis there were these little
things that you had on a key chain
insert graphic of Tamagotchi and you
would take care of this Tamagotchi that
I'm gonna make really hard to animate
later where is it
haha you if you remember Tamagotchi they
were a hit for like a few years and some
people still have them to this day I
know there's some people in the comments
right now that are still taking care of
their Tamagotchis but what they were
they were pets that you kept around and
it was like it was like it was like you
bought a key chain of responsibility you
bought something that you had to keep
alive and it was very hard to keep it
was very easy to let it die and then
you'd be sad so it was a little ball of
sadness and a little bit of happiness
that you carry around with you it's a
ticking time bomb of disappointment is
basically what that is but it was fun
maybe but this is hit tokachi which is
supposed to be the inverse of Tamagotchi
where you or I and the tama goat yeah I
don't know hello um hello I'm the person
assigned to take care of a monster ah
Vimy said who I am is this the right
house leave leave and never return
you've come and found the monster now
never go back tell everyone that he's a
screaming idiot with stupid red hair hey
that's kinda rude well I am a monster so
there you have it wait a minute you're
the girl stares at your face for an
awkward amount of time I know I'm
blazingly handsome it's a burden I have
to bear yeah you're the one oh um let me
introduce myself my name is Nadine and I
will be your personal caretaker for the
week this will be my first time taking
care of
non-human so I hope we get along you
sure you shouldn't have come here you
should I thought I warned you I thought
this I thought the posters of my face
outside the walls were enough to ward
anybody away he didn't have come here
now no need to be rude to someone you
just met
well then I'll be sorting my things
upstairs for a little while I'll see you
in a bit okay
the Dean brings her luggage as she goes
up the stairs so what should we do on
our first day together eat play sleep
talk only so long as I get to eat you I
guess we could talk so where's your
family I hate them I might have a little
bit ate them eat them wow that's funny
you spent time talking with Nadine time
for you to sleep I can't wait for
tomorrow you had a well-deserved rest oh
you're doing better than last time
what is that supposed to mean
morning what should we do today eat the
menu for today is nothing I'm sorry the
agency didn't give me any food for today
I'll eat you instead uh what are you
saying
why are you happy about that now don't
get the wrong ideas here
what do you have on your mind today Dean
brought a maracas shake shake shake you
see oh god I'm such an but I am
a monster you suck at your job I'm doing
what I can you shook the maracas hey I'm
how am i doing as a caretaker oh jeez oh
man well you didn't feed me so if I had
to give any answer it probably be yeah I
mean you brought maracas and I do like
maracas so so so really Thanks
I'll do my best for the rest of the week
blood doesn't that girl have it I wonder
how it tastes oh geez oh geez oh geez is
are these options gonna do what I think
they're gonna do kill kill her oh do you
need something just like the other ones
be done with it
what is it I don't know what I expected
monsters can't change you never learn do
you
oh I guess that's it then well
or not I done did a goof I goofed real
hard I did bad you guys are all
disappointed in me but don't worry I'm
gonna blast through this with expert
something or other hello hello it is the
right house indeed welcome come on in
how good I thought I went to the wrong
place for a second there wait a minute
you're the girl stairs your face you're
the one now first time taking care of a
nonhuman I'm sure we will we're gonna
get along great glad you think that too
I'll be sorting my things upstairs for a
little while see you in a bit so what
would should we do oh we should play
brought a ball she threw it fetch well
I'm not a dog hahaha sorry I'm not sure
about what things a nonhuman would one
you played along with her for a bit time
for you to sleep I can't wait for
tomorrow
blood blah blah No why is this an option
now oh is that so mm-hmm
morning all right let's talk have you
ever tried taking care of a pet they get
scared of me oh I don't think you're
scary you talked into Dean for awhile
what do you have on your mind maybe we
could eat oh this is where oh this is oh
okay I'll eat you instead which for some
reason causes you to blush your eyes go
star and a heart appear up in the top
I'm assuming what each of those slots
probably means another day
the week you're doing there you're doing
all right you doing okay stop trying to
be human she smells quite nice why is
that Monster shaped like a heart maybe
even better than the last just a little
flesh would be nice wouldn't it what are
you trying to say there buddy
who do you try to say oh no really now
accept it I don't know what I'm supposed
to be accepting I need food so that'd be
nice
time to wake up and get moving feed me
menu for today is pie homemade pie to be
exact I made it myself I hope you like
it it tastes good okay I finished eating
so that's a little bit better so maybe
I'm not gonna murder you what should we
do this afternoon well we should
probably play so um what are you usually
play I don't really know videogames hell
yes I see huh Nadine pondered for a long
while wait you pondered you didn't give
me a goddamn game back it's getting
quite late time to sleep blood does in
there girl have it oh god damn it no
it's been a few days since I started
taking care of you you weren't that bad
of a monster are you falling for me haha
you dummy
okay let's start the day with a bang
alright let's play
Nadine brought oh you brought video
games Hey look I'm sure you'll like it
it's a game where you roll this ball and
I played that before Oh in that case
will you give me some tips and tricks
about it you played along with Nadine
for a bit oh that's sweet hmm something
to do something to do well we could eat
the menu today is soup this wouldn't
really make you full huh it said
something I like soup
I'm a soup kind of guy hmm we should be
content with what we're giving finished
eating and cleaned up I'll be submitting
some reports to the agency tonight have
a good sleep I didn't get much sleep
today oh do you just want to sleep do
you want to aunty I'm taking the app you
want take a nap take a nap take a nap
take a nap
I'll sing you a song while you nap
you listen to the Dean as you slowly
drifted to sleep and he plans to do
something well we should probably the
menu for today is slime salad yay
this certainly looks quite appetizing I
know you should try it try it come on
try it is this a thing really edible
Nadine takes a bite you didn't tell her
that it's oh are you kidding me
on that what a load of ass dicks all
right so what I'm gonna do there's got
to be a way to get hearts on every
single one of them which is what I
imagine is gonna be good
police I guess maybe you go to school Oh
too cool for that way too cool you do
seem smart after all hey yeah yeah oh
should we do this afternoon I don't know
you have something on day three right hi
it tastes good it's real good getting
quite late time to sleep let's see
you're doing better hey I haven't even
had a night urge to eat her I think I'm
doing great
are you falling for me hey oh yeah all
right started off with a bang with
talking hey do you have any friends I'm
a monster I have no friends nobody
wanted me nobody liked me
and nobody wanted to be near me nobody
wanted me really you seemed like you
would be a really good friend to have
you had a fun conversation with Nadine
oh that's lovely
hmm something to do I'm guessing I need
to because that's what I need you have a
needs thing in the top-left so I'm
assuming I'm just gonna I'm gonna nip
nap the day away I'll read you something
as you sleep day one evening a lady
wearing white was sighted near my house
it was said that she you pretend to not
hear the story and fell asleep nice I
will be submitting some reports of the
agency tonight have a good sleep you had
a nice long sleep
you walk out feeling really great I
didn't get much sleep today do you want
to do you want to talk it out do you
want talk do you want to talk about it
so what are your hobbies not launching
them carrot cooking see I never thought
you'd be into that I'm a decent cook
myself would you teach me you converse
with Anna Dean as the hours go by and he
plans let's eat
no let's play no let's eat and this time
not you're not gonna get you're not
gonna die I know let's have something
else after this shall we
oh god damn it I was gonna end on a
good note what a good day that was we'll
see you tomorrow
well it was good wake up sunshine all is
well today is it is it really have you
ever fallen in love I fallen for you oh
come on you talked about love for some
reason who knows why dot the dot I'm a
little tired
well then let's sleep let's just sleep
be sleepy sleep ah sleeping early well
sweet dreams you too
you took a nap and felt something touch
your cheek oh it's the blood from my
ceiling oh it always flows and comforts
me so much so um tomorrow is our last
day
finally just just go I'll miss you so
much baby anyways I have to prepare for
tomorrow night night yet a well-deserved
rest
you're doing better than last time
supposedly good morning we should enjoy
this moment as much as we can ha let's
play yeah Nadine brings a Rubik's Cube
hey ever tried to solve one of these not
really I played this a lot when I was a
kid let me show you how Pro handles this
he played with him to Dean for a long
while dot dot dot dot dot Nadine's
nowhere to be found she left already
dot dot dot you felt a presence behind
you huh Oh Oh God
sorry I had to leave a little early I uh
went to the agency and asked if I could
have an extension on being a caretaker
Oh and I've grown fond of you and well
wanted to spend time with you more oh
geez oh gosh I love you I love you so
much I love everything about you
me too great oh no I don't have to eat
you if you were to rejected me I would
have just gobbled you up right on the
spot to save myself them the
embarrassment oh why do I have nails on
but drive nails in my head why am i
blushing with just the black of my skull
is that just where I radiate heat you
hugged Nadine ah what should we do today
[Music]
alright then we did good maybe I
don't know maybe that was good I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to understand and I'm
gonna look up a little bit of a
walkthrough to see if there was
something else that I could have done
there okay so apparently there's a
middle of the road ending that was the
best ending I did it I'm the master of
love no matter what I do I just fall in
love wherever I go except the real world
because that's not applicable anyway so
yeah there's a middle of the road ending
and then there's a good ending which is
what we got and then the bad ending is
when you eat her but maybe there's more
out there I'll put a link for the game
in the description below and maybe you
can try to find another ending it's
pretty fun I like it a lot it's charming
in a way and I believe this came from
Game Jam so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how I did down
the comments below and as always I will
see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]